bonsoir je m'appelle zimbra oui c'est
rhizomique bon je vais commencer à vous
poser une question qui se demandent
pourquoi je suis sur scène qui se dit
que filiale fille trisomique sur la
scène était d'ex casablanca cette
question là qu'est ce que tu fais là a
été le plus grand problème de ma vie
d'ailleurs il ya trois semaines
un journaliste se demander s'il fallait
autoriser l'avortement dans le cas où
l'enfant était diagnostiquée trisomique
leurs défauts d'ailleurs depuis tout
petit
le soufre ne pas avoir d'amis et le pire
ce que nous comprenons pas pourquoi les
après à 13 ans lorsque intrigue était
trisomique
lorsque mes parents me l'a annoncé lui
ai du mal à comprendre c'est vrai que
les accros maison puisque vous regardez
sur la paire 21 ici comme vous les deux
jambes deux bras on se voit un coeur
bien obtenu mon bac en 2014 avec mon
chien
cela m'a valu
reste donc la porte à man et m6 j'étais
également contacté par les médias et
fait du buzz sur les réseaux sociaux
elle ne comprenait pas de maison pas
handicapé de nombreuses personnes se
disent oh la pauvre maîtrise amical
handicapés mais n'oubliez pas que c'est
moi qui entre notamment plus alors que
c'est vous qui m'ont quelque chose avant
de terminer nouvelliste dire quelque
chose ne me sont pas handicapés
c'est vrai nello les gens qui pensent
que ce tribun que peut rien faire parce
que leur esprit n'est pas ouvert de voir
un autre monde en moins dont l'on
accepte la différence pour en faire une
force
un monde où l'on trouve ou trisomiques
autres enfants présentant des besoins
spécifiques et peuvent avoir une chance
de vivre leur f
ben je dis aux parents d'enfants nés en
présentant des besoins spécifiques
battez vous pour eux vraiment batibouw
coureurs ne laissez pas tomber dans le
mode de vivre leur rêve
mais pas pour tout le monde c'est la vie
c'est tout le monde moi c'est bon pour
eux récemment il faut savoir qu'il ya de
nombreux il ya des trisomiques de
nombreux qui sont des peintres cuisiner
eux mêmes acteurs moi je veux devenir
femme d'affaires mais de nombreux
métiers accessibles comme peintre
ouvriers apte à ses vrais bandits
diabaté vous pouvez certains klaus qui
vont eux ils s'attaquent le coup pour
rien sur lui réussi car le travail pour
une importe lequel d'entre vous tous
merci bonsoir